[Music]
all right we're rolling should we go
yeah is this video too yeah un I have a
beautiful hat there we go no I do it
makes me look like whoa you know hey
guys he's the head of the bowling league
well we're just
talking got the hilarious Eddie
pepperone here uh yeah I was just
talking I did uh I never do NPR I'm not
like I never get booked for NPR when I'm
from mod a special but I'm doing uh I'm
producing first special I've ever
produced Dena hasham special for Amazon
really she's hilarious it's great
special but what can I ask your question
and hi Eddie
pep what does that mean to produce a
special seriously just means I help try
to sell it it doesn't I mean he doesn't
really it that's producers yeah or or
like you know I mean I watched it and I
was like I'd cut this I'd cut but like
but I said it's your special and so
you're going to you're going to help try
to sell it yeah no it's on Amazon now
it's out now oh okay man he should
produce
yours well you had one it wasn't the
last one on Amazon uh the last one yes
that was hilarious by the way that was a
great Special K which one the last one
you put out yes it was called um for the
massive that was a great special I mean
it was uh thank you I still remember I
mean a lot of the bits uh the
one about the it was like the femdom
porn or something some really dark bit
like all now femdom porn that's your
thing I guess no but I know I've seen it
it was like it was domination Porter you
said something crazy in the one of the
bits yeah yeah yeah I get a lot of
mileage out of bondage pornography
that's what it was that's a great
sentence no uh it's hard to watch it in
LA because the sun is blaring oh the
time hard to jerk in the sun it
it's just it it's a mental thing it's
like you're watching people in hoods
they're hung from Hooks and outside it's
just beautiful it's just Birds right
right people jogging and you're like
what am I doing what am I doing indeed
Mark yeah but we we are Road Comics so
that hotel midday jerk is kind of nice
the amount I jerk off on the road is
it's like is I'm like what is this
vacation you'll never jerk off again
really I heard you can't you can't
finish it sucks yeah it it sucks the
Finish is really difficult on zolof you
know it's a bar I mean I think we were
raised as men oh it's great that you
don't come early right because I used to
come just you know on the phone call
with who trying to be fun it didn't work
um but um uh yeah this one it's tough
it's tough to finish really even with a
a pretty
hooker but with a hot lady it's uh it's
tough yeah it gets a little it you know
what's so funny it gets a little
pressurized the other way like instead
of like you're thinking of baseball to
try not to come the famous Woody Allen
bit if you remember great bit where he's
like don't think of Derek Jeter
hot guy don't think a Derek Jeter is
what I said he might come but he is a
Yankee all right if you heard it a bit
you heard it a bit and and and boy Woody
Allen I it's it's touchy now but anyway
he he was touch then
we're hot tonight we're hot tonight uh
he was like so I'm thinking of baseball
to try not come he goes uh so mcv's up
this is all in his head mccovy base hit
base hit I I pull a hit and run it works
lanir gets another base hit I got first
and third she's already in the
shower that was the punch like is that
he's so into the baseball his stand old
standup was it still holds up you know
ComEd doesn't age well it still is great
it does it's it's it's it's not topical
it's just Evergreen yes he's got
that great silly my wife tells me
I'm immature uh I was in the bath the
other day she came in and sunk my boats
yeah you know he's got a million of them
I love I mean Bullets Over Broadway to
me is his funniest movie that movie just
kills me dude me what's your
favorite line in that movie I got one I
love I love when she's narrating
um I fck Diane whis when she when she
walks in don't talk is that that's one
of them don't talk but I love when they
say uh you know she said Helen Sinclair
arrived late but she had a good excuse
and she goes my pedicurist had a stroke
she required she she landed right on my
feet they required
bandaging that's a great joke
that's like multiple jokes he really
like melbrooks who's also like a legend
you know by the way this podcast this
episode should be called called the
celebration of Woody
Allen Cosby next but Mel Brooks is the
same way they go for joke chokes yes in
their their yeah oh yeah God I
remember being shot even as a kid just
like watching being like holy I
cannot believe they're saying this were
you a prudish kid no
I it's just like they didn't make movies
like that you're like this is insane
yeah yeah the nword is said 800 times
and they cut a lot of I heard him
on Fresh Air talking about another NPR
ref really nping up a storm I was so
happy to be on anything NPR when I was
doing D thing because uh my my itinerary
when I have a special coming out it's
like bar stool bar stool it's like not a
lot of NPR in there you know oh bar
stool Sports yeah yeah okay cool um no I
don't know anything I I Bart you know
you're a big Nick fan I know that are
you a sports you're a New York guy too
I'm a big I was at the Ranger game last
night like I love hockey and football
and baseball but the Knicks were so bad
for so long dude I I just they good now
they're good okay they made the second
round of the playoffs last year they're
solid we'll see they're disappointment
every year what about you are
you I got the Saints they're all
disappointment you know they're like the
southern bills but uh Southern both
teams are pretty good well the bills are
pretty good bills are pretty good this
year but I like boxing in UFC you what I
like and you I prefer more of an
individual like a tennis you like
one-on-one I like one-on-one you're like
you're like uh Christopher Lloyd in One
Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest when
Nicholson was strangling big nurse do
you remember that and Christopher Lloyd
was just going kill him yes
killer he's like
Martini that's a great scene with nurse
ratchet and he's trying to
killher lyd because he like like you the
one-on-one combat and the martini how
great would it be if Danny DeVito was
and he's a corporate how great
would it be if he was Shilling for
Jersey mics as
Martini as Martini like in a hospital
gwn just oh it's good it's
good you know what annoys me so much is
there's these uh and I watch them all
I'm a whor for these things but
they have those Instagram Tik Tok people
who are just like in their car trying
sandwiches and stuff oh that's gotten
big got big dud and like literally
whatever joke we post you know doesn't
even touch them you know putting dress
on what the the guy the guy
is going like this is perfect he's
eating Jersey mics oh no he's
not he thinks he's a you
know eater but he's talking about it
like it's like fine dining you know and
he's like he's like you know dude
there's an Italian guy who's great a kid
do you know who I'm talking about young
guy meal by cougs cougs that skinny guy
he looks unhealthy as what well
he's just like I your sister the
whole time that guy oh oh no no this guy
goes a we are at
tulos the best and you believe him
because of the passion behind it the
best roast beef sandwich and he
eats and it's just like okay and while
I'm watching this from La going I'm
going to go to Tulio as soon as I get
back to New you know what I mean well I
think we got guy Fier to thing for this
you know you make fun of diners drives
and Dives I watch it every time it's on
per it's just great to back positive
like it's not good but he's just on he's
just like he's like this is a
sandwich I'm like that's the energy I
need when I'm in De Moine you know yeah
I guess that's what it is is this Nico
is that the New York NCO that's the dude
that's the dude his name is me what
what's it called cou cou by I think it
was Ken which is Italian for cousin or
Sicilian this
guy a little fresh action why in the car
this guy's going to die at 30 seven
though do you see every thing
he's like he a little more provolone I'm
like dude you're going to die
what did he say it it's just
great come on he seems so authentic to
me yeah DC acting I left it here
overnight it's nice and nice cold that's
fun but check him out he he is kind of
he like he's wearing no but now he's
wearing these like nice glasses which
trimmed sh like he he's obviously making
some money now right that's not cool how
many views you got up on this puppy yeah
how many I don't know I can't this feels
like look at how many comments wow this
is a ripoff though this isn't the guy's
actual page I don't think oh maybe yeah
what how do you know no it oh yeah maybe
right me's Twitter is not where they
should 2.6 million followers for trying
sandwich now by the way does it ever get
you down like that this right does
so much traffic and just about the medi
mediocrity of people in general like
what they're attracted to what do you
think Mark you're more of a people
person than I am and I think so is Sam
because Sam is like oh I need you know
it's great it's good energy I go with
the neg I no I come at it I come at it
from that's what we love about you no
that's your thing right we got good
energy on your bad energy that's right
yin yang but I don't think it's healthy
for me ultimately oh you're clearly
healthy all right but but no I mean I'm
just I think it's great you gotta but
you got to have your voice you know
you're that's your that's you you're
authentic yeah yeah I I I I just I just
later in life I've been like wow I'm
going to die soon you know I don't know
how soon I'll make it through this
you're going to make it way longer than
that kid that to they bash this
is your role how to get bashed all the
speeches of the funeral like he would
have he wouldn't have wanted me to eat
this sandwich while I gave this speech
oh that's that's a semolina roll
right there that's that's for
you buddy pour out a little Diet Coke on
his grave DC Diet Coke man I I are you
into that yeah yeah it's it's
addictive man but you can't blame him
you got to blame the masses cuz he's
just seeing what works and and and
giving them what they want who the
sandwich kid right right but it's it
just it's just to me depressing that the
worst I mean that's not the worst
but just people flock to
nothing high brow no like I would love
to do a YouTube channel where I'm just
talking about let's say Rembrandt but
like just little facts that people don't
know about rembrand like just make them
up too that rembrand had a deviated
septum
whatever I couldn't get it up yeah I
don't know that draw people yeah you're
right you're right I'd be like you know
what kind of pencil I used it wasn't a
number two it was
2.1 I don't know it's like a boring Bob
Ross you know yeah a boring Bob Ross
turns out he was a big Hound is
that right was he Bob Ross got a lot of
P he had a sex appeal he had the the
hair coming out of the shirt he had a
full Thro denim Sergeant in the Army who
yes and he was so sick of yelling he's
like I'm never doing that again is that
what happened is that right now that's a
great tidbit maybe that would have
happened to the guy in Full Metal Jacket
if he didn't get his head blown off you
know maybe he would have been a
painter afio didn't he blew his
own head off off that was him yeah
I worked with him and this isn't to come
at you cuz I'm sure you have things
going on but I worked with him in in a
show called uh deadline it was on for a
heartbeat on ABC and I was and he was
like I like a cop or something and I was
like a news reporter going Mr Johnson Mr
Johnson you know and that was
it did did you chat with him at all by
the way this is why I don't tell
stor because my stories go no
where yeah I know what you mean you've
been a lot of movies I feel like I'll
just be watching something be like
that's Eddie peperone you know
old so yeah old school best whoa that's
right dude I ju I I was in New York UCB
and Scott Armstrong who co-wrote it I
don't know if you know Scott he's a
writer and he co-wrote it and he just
comes up to me he was part of the UCB
crew and he goes uh hey would you like
to be in uh in a movie with Will Farrell
like this was right before Farrell old
school made Farrell yeah like big like
he was already big from SNL or whatever
but and and Roxberry like was a movie
was in you know something Roxberry with
Katan yeah is Katan still with us yes
barely barely he's hanging in there yes
for him to be relevant now it's it's a
lot isn't it like his big thing was the
Disco thing that was no that was the
movie Colin Quinn's in that movie is he
yeah one of my favorite Comics Colin
Quinn has a great cameo in that movie
where his whole character just asks uh
he goes did you just grab my ass that's
all he says the whole movie movie and
they're like no no no one is grabbing
your ass that's his whole character did
he do it more than once in the movie
Just Once no he's like he's a recurring
character it's a running gag so oh no
maybe the other guy asked him and he has
to say no but it's it's good it's a good
thing so what happened in Old SCH so
yeah I just want to tell you um that I
that Armstrong came up to me said would
you like to be in this movie I was like
yeah so I go to La had no idea I
was going to move to LA but they put me
up right next to uh Venice Beach so I
was on the water wow you know and I've
been landlocked here you know once you
get well as a New Yorker you know I
didn't I don't know if you guys do but I
don't go on boats here except the ferry
yeah the Staten Island Ferry you know
which I did fish off the back H A lot of
people don't know you can bring your own
Chum but anyway I I go out to LA and I
kind of it was incredible I was
hang out with Vince Fawn Luke Wilson and
Will Farrell yeah the other guys at my
level were Rob cordrey Simon hellberg
who became big with the um big bang
oh yeah and um a guy named Rick Gonzalez
who became a movie star too you know and
it was just incredible hanging with
farell and being right up close
watching him do his thing amazing crazy
Vince vaugh you both directed by the
same director oh yeah yeah Todd Phillips
what who very briefly in the Joker were
you in the Joker very I do stand up
before he goes on that was very brief oh
I have a lot of range you and uh I
have a lot of range I said but uh that's
cool as that you're with uh was how
was Vince Von to work with was he cool
he was very cool to me um but a little a
little CRA I remember he was smoking a
lot of cigarettes and Wilson Luke would
be
like and he kind of is an all american
guy Wilson that's what he looks like
anyway and he was like you got to stop
it Vince damn he's like this character
be
like and he'd be like I know I know I
know and uh I met Wilson once on Conan
we were on Conan together and he was so
freaking nice he came I had a good set
on that one he came in the green room
after or really and he was like I'm
going to keep my eye oh that's so never
never saw him ever again it was a nice
moment Well's but he's in the shadows
looking at
that's right that's right no he's a nice
dude though you know will frell such a
funny guy obviously trained
Shakespearean I think that's why he's so
funny cuz he's so serious in a comedy
movie and that's funny exactly that is a
great Insight yeah that is a great
Insight have you thought about
critiquing like acting work in
general like just a show called let's
take a look that's the name that's the
name of the show and you play Clips yeah
of like like an old like Shelly Winters
when she was
hot she was I don't know she was she was
hot we lost the she got fat she got very
fat oh really that's complacency I know
it oh yeah old school was great yeah
what other movies were you you a ton of
stuff um let's see I was in um The
Muppet Movie o really Jeff Dunhams all
right so Jeff Dunhams no uh it it was
with um who the
Amy Adams the red hair and and uh
Jason he was in uh How I Met Your Mother
oh seagull Jason seagull he's fun and
check it out there she is wow she was a
bomb show was a bombshell look at that
full figured gal a full figured gal and
it went South on her titties dude yeah
TI for days titties for days yeah yeah
beautiful yeah and I heard she liked to
fool around oh you know and she would
have been like look at her yeah there's
the picture later wow it doesn't go well
for I think any most people don't men
age better yeah we're lucky in that
regard but we we're rough we're rough in
in the young years I think so check it
out I'm on the set of uh there it is
you're a ton of dude Jesus yeah and
I'm on the side of the Muppet Terry was
another movie school for scoundrels oh
yeah um but the Muppet
movie I did a dance number the choreogra
I we played a postman it was like a
cameo they like they would do different
people doing little cameos and I danced
around this town square and the
choreographer was Mickey Rooney's son
Jesus and
he was he was in yellow face he was like
we're going to keep the tradition
going I don't get that reference I laugh
but I don't get reference of Tiffany he
was the Asian guy was he yeah he played
an Asian guy now I know why those folks
got so upset yeah with the Madam
butterfly with the Boxer Rebellion
particular I mean his his uh r rener
rendance no what do you call it
rendition of an Asian guy is pretty wild
oh my God there it is boy and what year
was that how 55 55 I'm guessing wow it's
in
color that's amazing oh yeah that kind
of stereotype 61 way off 61 so that
wasn't that long ago no by the way we
have no sense of time we think
1961 was forever ago like in it it's
nothing 80 years it's nothing we'll be
gone I think we're going to be gone here
comes my negativity Bring It On yeah I
think this how long do we have dude
really dude before the hits the fan
in this country I'll give you a number
and when I mean hits the fan I mean
it'll be violent here it will be
dangerous just to do anything n and
that'll be in 2027 I believe who 2027
just think about here we are now and and
Things Are are teetering or I think
things are teetering already yeah you
know I know it's going well for you
guys and that's what we tend to look at
like hey I'm in
Boise you know yeah that that was my
highlight this
year Bo nice place very clean air yeah
nice people clean air there's a lot of
survivalists there yes yes you know but
what about the election next year it's
the Democrats cannot run Biden no but
they will they can't but they will they
will and they'll lose I don't know if
they will run them and then we're going
to get Donnie again well they say that
Gavin noose might slide in oh come on I
bet he run I bet he runs I'm calling
right now maybe yeah yeah maybe I don't
know if he'll win but I'm saying I bet
he runs yeah yeah yeah I don't think
he's got a lot of popularity he's got
good hair he's terrific he he's terrific
looking yes he looks like a news he's
terrific looking the way like a Batman
villain is good looking you're like yeah
sure Aaron eart is handsome you know but
it's like something I don't know I'm not
saying I'm a fan I'm just saying I think
he's right right look at that guy he's
like a like a Californians hate him
though some do but he won again mostly
he recently voted against giving the
actors unemployment like
strike yeah he also did a he passed a
law that made test scores easier or
lower standards for black kids or
whatever and I'm like what what are you
doing yeah that feels weirdly racist
yeah he's uh what you call a lib a
a lib so you think your
prediction is Trump wins and then it go
and then it goes down the toilet he
pulling well yeah yeah totally yeah oh
by and plus the world if you're checking
out out the world it's did something
happen globally this is this is it and I
don't know if you guys are but I like to
come from this point of view on stage
even though a lot of people aren't into
it that globally man it's the oppressor
against the oppressed and the oppressed
are starting to rise up and it's just
going to be chaos oh yeah you know the
chaos we're witnessing in the midd East
which I think is going to grow yeah that
War I think is going to expand you know
right yeah doesn't seem good it's good
television but it's
brutal but have you seen is it
cake well that's the dichotomy right and
that's the thing I talk about a lot is
like and I'm I'm as guilty as anybody
the distractions like what the do
we care oh yeah about what's going on in
the midd East when right in our
neighborhood a great Macaroon Shop just
opened up and and they the technology
now the baking technology with macaroons
is amazing I love a macaroon they're oh
they melt in your mouth and
you're going to give a about
exactly what's going on yeah yeah
there's a new Indiana Jones coming out I
mean there's a new is that right well
they just had one yeah they look great
no I I think it I love those growing up
but they everything they just keep
making the same sh same same that
no one's taking risk except you know
what I like there's a new movie coming
out with Natalie Portman have you heard
about this movie Natalie because one of
the things I got for homework for you
guys we got say idiot you guys is uh oh
recommend something she's in my top five
by the way a new natal Todd Haynes there
it is oh he's a good director Todd ha
holy Todd Haynes a gay man he did he did
a he's gay that explains that explains
he did a very strange movie it's on
YouTube or something it's it's a it's on
the Carpenters and he has Karen
Carpenter as they're just dolls the
whole movie really and it's about her
downfall in bulimia I want to watch that
it's actually really cool check this out
interesting so here's the you see that
guy on the left Charles Melton okay so
the premise of the movie is Julianne
Moore was a teacher and slept with her
7eventh grade student which was Charles
Melton she went to jail she gets out of
jail and she hooks up with him again
because they're soulmates hell yeah
Natalie Portman is a journalist who
comes to do a story on it and spend some
time with him and she falls in love with
him wow this guy's a
Pro and so it's an intense sick sick
moovie those are my favorite those you
ever see the movie to die for with
Nicole Kidman that's a great movie yeah
I love dark com
yeah really is she fun I I dig her in
anything she does did you see
uh big little lies yeah my wife it did
did you that's so I watched it yeah it's
good wasn't it good I was like at first
and this is me this is me in a nutshell
like I'm looking at the trailer
like oh it's about a bunch of rich
in Monteray California beautiful scenery
I'm like these people and then I
watch it I'm like oh yeah oh yeah it's
basically
but the fun thing about those shows is
it's basically real estate porn so
you're like Kind Porn that's how I feel
about succession you're just like I get
to look at these sick that's
true but I never saw a succession porn
has great real estate as well even by
the way porn just regular porn had
they're like on a stairwell I'm
like this is a beautiful home that's
beautiful stairwell I always look for
things in porn like wow they really they
they don't they don't give you any idea
where you are right every room has to be
blank yes you know and I always look for
oh maybe there'll be like a Jimmy
Buffett CD like get some insight into
the homeowner yeah but no right give me
a Fraser box set a Frasier box
set oh god oh there you go oh god oh
that's a good time so this is a this is
a good movie it's not out yet though
which yeah May December or may I forget
what it's called but it's a December
it's uh it's just from the trailer
here's another sick twist twisted I like
Twisted emotional hell yeah did you ever
hear the movie damage with Jeremy Irons
no check it out here's the premise of
this one Jeremy Irons has like a tense
relationship with his
son and his son's about to get married
to Juliet benos right by the way they
look so old in these pictures you're
pulling up but anyway his son's about to
get married and they have a father-son
relationship that's Frau with a lot of
jerem Juliet benos and Jeremy
Irons the father get attracted to each
other and the father sleeps with his
son's
fiance and that is like that's
Shakespearean exactly oo that's hot and
I'm watching that just going yes oh
yeah well like porn with good dialogue
oh yeah it is it's like it's what a lot
of these premises are you just like
shouldn't be doing this you're like shut
up it's a better line right right
cinematography too yeah that's a good
point yeah it's elevated porn remember
that movie Unfaithful that was hot which
one was that Diane Lane and that super
hot Hispanic guy yeah R Julia or no way
hotter well he was longy came out
younger he's a young buck that I don't
think ever worked again that guy he
never worked again Paul tell
well Dian Lane was a dime piece
in that movie whose mother is she she's
the mother
of Laura D oh okay sorry different Lane
but go go scroll up a smooch that she's
the mom oh yeah she's the mom of Laura D
who's really yeah wow you know what
movie I watched the other day I'd never
seen it was pretty cool is uh you ever
see the Spanish Prisoner David Mammoth
it's pretty fun yes I haven't watched
that in a while is it good it it's a
Twist movie
yeah it's like they lulling you along
it's weird but I I was yeah it's weird
and mammoth's
dialogue I he used to be my favorite cuz
I I studied acting and this is again not
to hurt you no that I'm sure you we saw
your IMDb dude you're no but I
yeah you're St you know I don't want to
step on any toes
here her daughter Ellena
Lambert look at Ellena Lambert I'm not
allowed to
these people are great anyway
um what was I I was talking about what
mammoth in acting school when I was in
acting school dude did did you ever uh
read or see sexual perversity in
Chicago never heard of it how about
American buffalo I've heard never seen
it Vince Gallow yeah oh is he in that I
think he directed yeah he's sick he's a
sick puppy oh yeah Buffalo 66 that's
what I'm sorry you see you're not you're
not
right yeah wrong Buffalo yeah I guess I
can't talk theater with you guys I no no
and that's fine Buffalo Wild bar sto if
you want to talk bar
stool Sports we're not disc cultured
we're working on American buffalo there
you go no but
mammo mammoth's dialogue and tell me if
you didn't notice this Sam doring
Spanish Prisoner the dialogue is a
little for it's a little in this one
it's not he doesn't even curse in this
one it's kind of a weird it's a more
restrained script yeah it's it's kind of
who's in it oh there he is uh it's
Campbell Scott I like Campell he's great
yeah and Steve Martin is in it Steve
plays it's like very against type all
right it's pretty cool yeah okay I'll
check it out also House of games is a
cool MMO one too I thought with the I
liked house games that's a cool one he
threw his wife in that one lindsy Krauss
yeah ah people do that they throw their
you know his next wife is in this one
his what his next wife is in a Spanish
Prisoner oh you got a Phil Spectre movie
I'll check that out is there oh oh
Mammoth wrote the screenplay I guess
hell yeah yeah Ed Edmond can you click
on Edmond is that Macy oh my yeah that
is Macy works with him all the time
because they're from the Chicago theater
scene have you heard of good Something
Good Fellas
Goodwill
Hunting good burger good burger is there
a good burger yeah there is with Kenan
where that was like old school that was
our childhood it's a Nickelodeon comedy
oh with Keenan and Cal and Keenan and
Cal yes that's it welcome to
Goodburger all right anyway Edmond I
don't know Edmond Edmond click on Edmond
good flick uh Matt can you click on
admin oh Sierra DVD a man becomes
involved in a Twisted game of sexiz and
murder with three young women Denise
Rich mea suari and you could do worse
than these triple whes Joe Mont is great
I remember uh doing a guy's podcast he's
a guy who was famous and he goes who are
your childhood crushes and I and I said
uh I don't know Denise richers is really
hot he goes name some more I go Jennifer
Love he it he's like uhhuh he goes to
break he goes them both wow and I
was like are you serious I won't say his
name all right right I'm going to just
throw out some
names well what I'll do is I'll look at
your podcast history yeah right was not
ours it was Neil Brennan's
pod wow them both who's this
Carson Dy that's incredible Carson I
don't think he's got game to you whoa
Carson daily dated Jennifer Love H it oh
he did for a hot minute yeah he had a
run he had a run he's a cute little guy
and he had a talk show I me he was big
he was an MTV guy I know but come on
we're comics and he's not one of us no
no you got that right right he's not one
of us oh terara Reed and him were they
him would
love okay
okay T seemed like she could have been a
lot though yeah she's a nightmare OT
Kimmel got him in the biz no way yeah
Kimmel got a lot of Bill Simmons Corolla
he got Sim yeah he got all these people
in Corolla
oh Ashley Simpson Jamie Presley man this
guy was on a roll good for him this guy
was everywhere he does look a
little like okay he's he's been damaged
by life you have to be damaged by life
to to want this kind of Lifestyle wait
wait is he married to a woman named Siri
printer what that can't be right oh Siri
Pinter okay I was about to say this is
that Harold is that a relation to Harold
Pinter uh oh give it a goo who's Harold
Pinter ah great famous playright really
yeah famous playright uh betrayal was no
Mark Pinter's a good pull though I like
where your head's at anyway I'm talking
too much theater to you guys well it's
it's even though what really looks good
on Broadway I get off at JFK again not
to break that kind of Lifestyle I get
off at JFK and a huge moral mural a huge
mural yeah that's a a huge mural of a
new Broadway musical called shucked I
saw with the corn I I had a good laugh
about that that's where we're at yeah
that there you go and uh look at this my
friend is a theater person and she goes
I just feel sorry for all the people in
that cab because she knows what just
look at them is it a musical what is
this yeah oh yeah it's got a kernel of
Truth did they say that as that I'm just
throwing that out there you see you
would be great on the team no on the pr
team for sure oh yeah you know what I
mean yeah yeah yeah yeah you know um
yeah shooked I don't know I don't know
usually they pull it from a movie or you
know hey we'll do a show a new thing
it's all movies it's all movies oh the
Broadway sty yeah it's pathetic man I
remember the big one was Spider-Man on
Broadway and it just it just like
couldn't open it was like cursed it
couldn't open that would be a funny show
is like a failing giant play where like
one guy get he's Spider-Man dude did you
ever see Noises Off do you guys know
that play check that out they made a
movie of it too but the play is way
better it's about a production that goes
Haywire I saw it on Broadway
with Peter Gallagher if you remember him
I'm talking too much no I met him once
in a in a store I was in like pet G I
was in like seventh grade in in a bodega
and I was pissed drunk with a friend of
mine and I was like you're Peter
gallager and his wife and he was like GH
he could tell he was just like this
drunk kid and his wife was like that's
so sweet he knows
you see his wife knows what's
up where
Gallagher is short that Vision he
had he's a good actor oh yeah yeah yeah
I haven't heard anything too he he can
sing he did like Guys and Dolls and
he's like Solid cast you got Patty Leone
and Jane curtain holy from what
what is it this is oh Noises Off Michael
fret dude if you get a chance
there's Rex here yeah play is so funny
it's just about it how it goes Haywire
have you ever been in a play either
either oh yeah I grew up in plays I was
big play guy yeah isn't it the
real play is just what Sam said what
goes on behind the scenes the little
romances that always happening always
you know and the fighting oh and
the lighting guy is mad and then the the
one guy had the prop guy has got a
vision and everybody hates him and yeah
and you find out the guy running the
soundboard is Ed in like three
Midwestern states exactly exactly you
mean Joe's real name is Arie you know
that kind of thing yeah and you go in
the the set designer guy garage and it's
just swastikas all stuff yeah there's
always I'm an alleged human trafficker
okay yeah how do they job I guess
they're PE I I always say in job
interviews well I'm a people person and
it usually helps me when when I was
looking for work back in the day so why
do you want to wait T I used to wait
table in New York and uh they' be so why
do you want to work um here at s
steakhous a French Steakhouse again I
don't want to hurt you
um you know was up scale oh okay and
they they'd be like what do you want and
I'm like I just I'm a people person and
he the guy looks at me and he goes come
on man like he called me on yeah that's
great and I said I so then I said okay
you want this level you want truths I go
like Nicholson and A Few Good Men I go I
need the money
Frank I need the money I got I got my
balls against the
wall you know I got a I got a
dental bill out the
ass and then he goes okay but do you
like our food wine and I go oh that's
the level of Truth you want and he said
we'll be in
touch
well you got the job I did hey there you
go I did I did there was a fire a lot of
waiters got hurt so I was called
in did you I waited tables for 10 years
you did oh is it a brutal here it's
brutal no never in New York thank God
but I would eat everything off the
plates were you a plate eater oh yeah I
mean if it's a shrimp it's it's
individual you know it's did they touch
it no they didn't touch it let's do it
it's got a casing on it we would go in
the garage the C had a big garage in
Midtown I think it's still there and
we'd go in the garage and eat oh
yeah and smoke joints oh yeah and I
would go to tables sometimes I got too
high and I would I got fired on a night
I was high because I went to a table
three times with the bottle of wine and
ruined the cork three times like oh
sorry I'll get you in not rebottle wow
and it was a family they were uptight
the the father was uptight and I did
after the third time he goes I want
another waiter oh that's devastating and
that was when I got called on the carpet
the next day yeah you know I said but
come on I'm a
people yeah I used to wait tables at
this high-end play I was trying to make
a couple bucks called The Windsor Court
it was like a highend New Orleans and
this was like old school debutant
southern white rich people I had a
crummer you know you had a crummer you
know that and I had white jacket
the whole thing I was to so out of place
hung over every time get there 5: in the
morning you had to chop you it was
brutal it was a horrible it was like the
military but uh opening the wine was so
scary it stressful you're you're
right on the spot and they're like you
know I'm 19 or whatever I'm hung over
I'm sweating vodka and I'm
like then you you break it and then you
have to redo it then you ask the old guy
to help oh my God it was the old guy to
help
yeah that was a tough gig there it is
the Windsor Court I mean it was old
school slavery going
on holy lot of men julips floating
around oh yeah a lot of sear sucker look
at that it's like the Last Supper oh my
God that's like crazy that's like
beautiful would it be people like oh
we're going to get ourselves a nice
bottle of Sher I do declare do I
guarantee we doing that new wedding with
a lot of us face going I do oh yeah
it was down there stav is going I do
declare I'm going to get my Pekka suck
tonight where is it at Mark's wedding it
was New Orleans I saw pictures of your
wedding it looked like fun oh it was a
hoot and a holler it was yeah where' you
do at New Orleans right in the French
Quarter holy I don't know how you
people you're you grew up there yeah how
do you survive the Summers there oh it's
a nightmare I I always say new or is
great to visit it's fun but living there
is like a drag queen in the morning you
know it's fun at night Sparkles and
everything but in the morning you know
when you live there you see the the next
day you know it ain't pretty and you
have those like flying roaches right
that's like a New Orleans thing yeah
they cockroaches that fly yeah that's
another can I have a napkin I have to
please sorry what do you got
tobacco no I hey we might be drunk is
brought to you by fume their entire
courses about how to break habits it's
not easy baby but fume is here to make
it simpler fume is an Innovative award
nominated device that lets you keep the
habit but gets rid of the bad there's no
electronics no vapor and no harmful
chemicals here just all natural flavored
air fume even works as a fidget toy with
the movable parts and magnets to keep
your hands busy I love fume I like to
just hold it play with it put it in my
mouth blow it jizz on it with six
awesome flavor cores to choose from and
an adjustable air flow dial ditching
your bad habit just got much
easier stopping something we all put off
because it's hard but switching to fume
is easy enjoyable and fun fume has
served over 100,000 customers and has
thousands of success stories and there's
no reason that can't be you join fume in
accelerating Humanity's breakup from
destructive Habits by picking up the
journey pack today head to
trium.vira today that's try f.com and
use code drunk to save an additional 10%
off your order today hey hey folks we
might be drunk is brought to you by
manscaped put smooth balls on your
Christmas list this holiday season
manscapes new performance package 5.0
Ultra has everything you need to make
your package look great it comes with
the lawnmower 5.0 Ultra body trimmer the
weed whacker 2.0 ear and nose hair
trimmer they're crop Soother aftershave
lotion and crop preserver ball deodorant
they're also throwing in two free gifts
super comfy boxers and a travel bag to
store your
stuff I love manscape I keep it in my
suitcase you know me it's got the light
on it I feel like I'm doing some real
mowing down there I get it all up on the
sides and the shaft I got to keep it
trimmed not a lot of inches to work with
so get on it look good feel good the
ladies appreciate it or the men the lawn
more 5.0 Ultra does it all it comes with
two blade heads and a standard trimmer
blade and a foil blade for a super
smooth finish and it's waterproof
shaving the shower manscape skin safe
technology you won't even be scared to
go over that super close shave right
before the big holiday party the
performance package has everything you
need to shape up look feel and smell
amazing get 20% off and free shipping
with the code drunk manscape.com that's
20% off with free shipping at
manscape.com code
drunk hey DraftKings baby this year I'm
thankful for a week of NFL football and
DraftKings sports book is keeping me
extra thankful new customers can bet
just five bucks on the NFL action to
score 150 instantly in bonus bets no
matter your appetite there something for
you money lines parlays props live bets
and much more You Name It We got it so
download the draftking Sportsbook app
now and use code
wnb
wmbd sorry new customers can bet live on
the NFL Thanksgiving action to score 150
instantly in bonus bets only on
draftking sports book an official sports
betting partner of the NFL with code
wmbd the crown is yours gambling problem
call 1800 Gambler in New York call 8778
Hope and why or text Hope and why to uh
get help in West Virginia visit
ww. 1800 gambler. net please play
responsibly in Connecticut you know what
to do on behalf of Bot Hill Casino and
Resort Kansas you must be 21 or older in
most eligible States but ages vary by
jurisdiction C draftkings.com Sportsbook
for details in state specific
responsible gambling resources
eligibility and deposit restrictions
apply bonus bets
expire 168 hours after in issu issuance
issuance terms at sports book.
draftkings.com
terms you know what sounds more fun than
all these words is gambling yeah just go
to that
gamble hey hey folks we might be drunk
is brought to you
by
Aura we all have that one ridiculous
photo that our family thinks is
hysterical you might want to keep it off
of social media but it's the perfect
thing to put in a digital picture frame
with three unlimited storage with free
unlimited storage you can send as many
photos to the frame as you want and I'll
allow an unlimited number of people to
send their own pictures to it go ahead
start an AA photo frame with your family
your friend group or even gift one to
your boss so that you can add a little
fun to the workplace pretty cool frames
get old this a same picture in there
from 1988 where you got a double chin
and jizz in your eye and all that and
but this will rotate them this is the
way to do it now everybody can see all
the photos you don't have to buy 18
frames and cover your whole desk it's
pretty good pretty good idea Aura is
even interactive reactive photos with
Emojis send your congratulations and
more from now through Black Friday and
saber Monday Aura is offering their best
deal of the Year listeners can save on
the perfect gift by visiting Aura
frames.com drunk that's a a frames.com
drunk use promo code drunk to get 40%
off they're bestselling frames terms and
condition May apply get on it it's a
perfect gift we cut that out disease but
um okay what was I gonna say that's
another thing I didn't mention in this
collapse of civilization that is going
to happen happen sooner than anyone
thinks is this good for your audience oh
yeah so is the Eco stuff like you're
talking about flying roaches the
pandemic was an animal thing it's going
to get worse yeah yeah it's only could
go down you know it can't go up no I
mean just the diseases the
pandemics the virus the pandemic I mean
the pandemic almost killed all of us in
a sense like the mental illness the the
mental illness was the worst part I
think I think it revealed a lot of yes a
lot of mental problems that we that we
all have right and some people just
snapped to see people s yeah I think a
lot love Zoom now Zoom was great I love
Zoom I personally I like the shows the
comedy you did it you're very oh you
funny come on that was I remember
being in my I I did a zoom show the
first one I did and I was in my
kitchen and really trying to give it to
my o and about 2 minutes in I was like
this is stupid yeah I couldn't hear
anybody yeah you know my friend put it
best he said it sucks to bomb at home
you know because if you bomb at the club
you go all right I'm getting out of here
and you can wash it off a little at home
but at at home you just go from there to
the couch your wife has seen you it's
literally like a sex robot versus a live
you know a real woman I feel like a live
show is a real woman and and the zoom is
like a robot or whatever I don't
nothing me and my wife have sex now on
Zoom so that that is a good thing for me
you know because my body's gotten a
little tired of all of it sure how long
have you been married uh 10 years oh
that's not bad it's not long 10 nice
yeah yeah so like kind of later right
it's what I mean you weren't married
super young that's kind of nice no I
wasn't married young at all man as a
matter of fact I since it's a hard I
think marriage is very hard I don't know
what you think I it's so difficult you
know are you new you're newly married oh
I can't you no bring it on want the
wisdom no I'm saying that I'm sure
you're great right now but it becomes
20127 it's all going down the marriage
too you you and your wife are going to
have to survive you know the the era of
makeshift weapons Etc that might bring
you two together though something do
together yeah honey honey we got to
sharpen the
broom that's what I'll be doing Shar
sharpening like mop sticks it's like
prison it's got we're in prison you got
to have a shank yeah okay good to know I
I don't think the three of us are
equipped for what's going to happen no
absolutely no way you got allergies he
needs pep allergies yeah I have bad
digestive right right I'm and I'm going
to need my Z off like I'll be like I'll
be like I need my I'll be telling this
to like whatever alt right like I figure
I'll be strapped to like one of those
huge trucks in the front like in Mad Max
you know just telling Jo like I'll be
earning my keep by going uh all right I
have sex with my wife on Zoom like just
trying to stay alone Comics will be big
then what Jeff Ross Jeffrey Ross will be
strapped to a tank and be like oh yeah
tell your face a lot of
that insulting Rand you got to keep the
morale up yeah that's true absolutely
yeah there's no funny people in Mad Max
or water world there's no by which is
why I wasn't crazy about the Mad Max
movies you nailed it for me no
humor at all no comedy escape from New
York's got humor that's true you got
like brain and stuff you got you know
you got some weirdos that's true Ernest
borg9 yeah that's right he brings so
much humor yeah I love I love that guy
that my friend we went and saw flower
moon or whatever the scor yeah it's it's
fun it's not
fun it's it's I found it to be the
Feelgood film of the holiday season yeah
but my point is it didn't have that
Scorsese humor like Casino has a lot of
jokes Wolf of Wall Street has a lot of
jokes The Departed there funniness they
had no Scorsese little uh irony or or
you know serious subject matter man I
guess so I you know what's scary is to
see dairo I didn't see the movie but I
saw a couple of stills of dairo and he
looks so serious oh he's great in it but
yeah he serious just incredible when
he's like you know that dead on
like the movie which did have humor good
was it good Fellas where dairo was
whacking everybody MH like and they
would stop at slow motion that meant
you're dead remember yeah
right him just smoking a
cigarette that's cool ass shot
but oh man uh yeah no I I I'm I'm with
you it wasn't there wasn't enough like
you need a release of tension when oh
you saw it too yeah I didn't I didn't
love it to be honest is it in the
theater is that where you saw it scorsi
I go right to it go right I love scores
the other one Tarantino me too me too I
feel like you'd be good in a Tarantino I
would love to be Kate berant got in the
last one I wrote her Mage you
did I was like I just saw you in a
little Hollywood congrats yeah I should
tell her that ah it's been enough time
you missed the window I did miss the
window seven years AG he making one more
uh no the movie critic right that's what
it's called Tarantino he's only got what
two left I think this is it this is it
no I thought I thought Hollywood ending
was his last no no he's got one more oh
I can't wait to see that the movie
critic he oh that must be fun movie he
can just do whatever he wants I mean and
people will say he's proved to me too
that DiCaprio and pit are way more than
just pretty boys oh yeah what
great actors both of those guys are well
I mean DiCaprio came out of the gate
with a special needs kid true oh what
was that gil Gilbert oh that's right
Basketball Diaries He was solid too I
mean I think the Jim Carol thing is that
what it was I don't know I'm sorry it's
not a Christmas movie no I I think I
would is Right Basketball Diaries is
about all these people it's about Jim
Carol you're right who his life as a
high school basketball 47% on Rotten tea
come on Bruno Kirby died so young line
brco was the therapist in uh Sopranos
and Good Fellas she was
in movies are great to talk about huh is
it because we all it's like a shared
it's our shared culture and Sport too I
guess if you're a sports fan is there is
there not anything worse than being in a
group of people and a few of them aren't
into sports women dude I know it's crazy
and I'm very sensitive to that like a
lot of guys will just or a lot of people
would just keep going and I'll
be like no no
Dolores Dolores is
Bored well they don't like their
basketball they don't like the women's
basketball they don't watch um yeah I
like it you you're a that's your
number one no it's not basketball oh
yeah basketball yeah yeah what what you
think WNBA I thought he same as no NBA
is my number one but but I like I like
the WNBA though I do oh yeah yeah I can
watch that yeah I I just love basketball
first but yeah you what are you baseball
hockey hockey hockey Hoy won and then
base Yankees and Giants the Giants are
so bad in football I'm a football tough
to watch what they're just it's tough to
watch they never gave a chance now it's
like watching are yeah you like the
Saints now the Giants are like watching
just like horrible traffic jam like it's
just like I don't even hear about the GI
I hear about the Jets a little and then
they got killed the other night the Jets
tease success but you know and the Aaron
Rogers thing was like the greatest
how about that how about that the VAC
got
him no but uh you know the Giants it was
just like they they went from like an
interesting playoff team last year to
probably the worst team in the league
it's pretty crazy they're really they're
really yeah it really and it really hurt
me because I was very up for this year
yeah like I you need a distraction when
the world is this up you sports
are important are huge the rangers they
look like they're going to be big time
cup contenders this year they're
awesome I think when when the the
streamers these apples or Amazon when
they take Sports TV's done what else
besides news and sports is getting
people to watch TV yeah TV is uh
although it is nice to have an escape
from like when you turn on Netflix at
least you're not going to see the news
at least you know when you turn on
Amazon you're talking about streamer
like you you're talking about Network TV
is going to be done that's what I'm
saying yeah 2027 all they have is sports
and news
yeah actually when the goes down
the news gets very good it goes way up
yeah it's like I'm down here and
they're the technology has gotten so
good with filming and oh yeah
they're on the ground and there's
stabbings going on right next to them
and you're like smoking a joint and I
order in for instance I order in you you
I I love hurricanes you probably don't
New Orleans but in LA to watch a thing
go to category
5 and when it makes landfall I always
make sure I have like a pizza or
something you know what I mean like to
watch I get it I mean you see that patio
furniture going in Florida and you're
like hey all right this is good TV but I
know that people have hurricane parties
in zones we had them yeah that
was a big deal school was shut down so
you got after it you got after it yeah
sometimes it rained enough you get a
canoe out there down down Main Street
you know it was it was crazy in New York
when the cuz the Subways when
they were flooded oh that was wild CRA
sh dude that's the future that is what
I'm talking about with the Eco
cities underwater you know you know what
might be cool is like you throw on like
scuba gear and you just the
train still moves you get on it could be
kind of fun that's futuristic yeah I
like that and New Yorkers are like
underwater still pushing they get on the
train right you get like a little
mariachi band still coming on not s for
some
reason show time Showtime Showtime show
and and for some reason the
announcements are clearer under waterer
for some reason that's hilarious nobody
knows why I like the hobo coming
on the government you know and the
dangerous people are less dangerous
underwater cuz they can't move as quick
you know how about the one
guy I was trying to work on a bit about
like when you I made eye contact with a
crazy guy in the train and that's like
the closest you come to feeling like uh
like a woman in a bar where you
accidentally lock eyes you're like
he's coming over oh that's funny man
that's funny but it's such a it's such a
awful moment where you're like I
I saw a guy getting it's like
yesterday I just walking around I saw a
guy getting yelled at by just a crazy
dude and you're just like the part's
like do I stay and make sure he's okay
but you're like I'm going to rush I
can't you know tough it's tough It's New
York I usually am also in a
you know so what you grew up here what
was it like on Staten Island in the 30s
I mean uh you know Big Jim Brady ran to
town no
um so I was born in Brooklyn and at 9
years old my dad moved us to the country
which was Staten Island and I got to
tell you though his dad was Christa
Stephano
yeah I got to tell you though we were
the only when I when I moved moved there
uh we were the only house on the Block
surrounded by woods and I thought I felt
like I was in a horror movie like I was
like man how old were you for this
I was in my
40s that's an old joke but very good
That's a
classic it's a classic so the the the
island grew quickly oh my God yeah but
we were when it they called the verizo
bridge the guinea gank plank wow because
so many Italians moved to Staten Island
right and um from Brooklyn and we were
we were one of them you are you Italian
my dad's Sicilian my mom's Jewish okay
my dad's Sicilian they're both dead ah
mob got godamn it godamn it age
takes us
all my mom is Sicilian is that right oh
yeah oh that's why I yeah do you
identify as Jewish cuz you're mom or no
not I'm Itali
very I'm in a rush
yeah was it kind of nice going back
because you live in the country and you
got to go back to the big the big the
big apple well I was always a city kid I
hated Staten Island yeah Pete
Davidson you know I mean this whole
thing about o it is such a hole
uhhuh you know know then and God blessed
him now that's what Don Rickles Pete
still lives there Pete's sticking with
it and the joker Sal volano lives there
Chris D no Chris Chris is coming back I
have no interest whatsoever in Staten
Island no there's nothing there there's
no culture there yeah you feel
disconnected whenever like I gotta get I
got my first VX there it was great it
was great for first vac my first vacine
why there because there was no why no
one gave oh because there it's a trump
air that's like very red well that's
when I that's when it was like you were
like really excited to get the vaccine
so I was too dude but so then I got it
and uh oh my God it was so easy I was
like no appointments then in Manhattan
it was like impossible yeah so it was
yeah it was great it was I I'm
such an idiot the I got the Johnson and
Johnson yeah and I thought I was doing
great I was like I and I had to go
outside of La Big Time like yeah by the
way I love that they were like by the
way there's one bad one you're like out
a three that's pretty bad yeah you're
you got to have good ones that's
true that is true blood clots I heard
for Johnson and Johnson yeah I don't
feel well now don't listen don't listen
to anything we say medically we're
idiots we'll put a little
disclaimer still still doing
misinformation I hear I hear it's blood
clots no we don't know no no no but
no I remember being excited to get it
instead was a spot oh look at that you
got a ferris wheel
now I didn't know that I've never the
case for living on Staten Island a lot
of mobsters move there well Chris D
Stefano our friend live moved there and
he's back now but when he was was living
there remember doing his podcast in
Staten Island he was like you got to
move here he was saying that the way you
push a guy to come to a party you know
his bad yes you know when the GU like no
this part friends there that's it you
know you know what they say when it's a
good neighborhood we're all we're all
booked up here good point there's no
there's not really any availabilities
that's true that's true that's true but
also you're in s island you have to get
get to this the city is where it's at of
course because nice parts of Sten Island
I just I wouldn't want to you know I
wouldn't want to want to live there I'd
rather live in the other four Burrows by
a lot yeah yeah yeah well just getting
back here is the boat takes forever and
then the the bridge is $8 million toll
it's unbelievable it's crazy tolls what
is the bridge now there's payment plans
now for the ver I know right I believe
it's 16 bucks it's unbelievable when I
was a child it was a nickel no no I'm
kidding that sounds very funny that
sounds
funny yeah I don't uh I wouldn't want to
live there guine gang plank for owner no
that's that's old oh no really oh well
that's with Easy Pass oh that's easy
pass everybody's got an easy pass I know
so I'm thinking of moving because my
sister had when we're very tight my
sister again not to hurt that I have
that kind of relationship uh with
family family is everything to us every
comedian just stopped listening they're
like I can't this oh no I had a
disastrous upbringing but really my
sister has yes you perked up huh yeah
crazy touched it was crazy huh
say didd oh no okay no that's the one
thing I didn't get all right well you
weren you weren't cute enough no they
they funny that you broke funny to say
that's the one thing didn't get yeah
like it's a Nintendo
yeah two things I never got a Teddy rug
spin or
molested next Christmas but um my sister
has a house in Woodstock New York and
Woodstock the Hudson Valley it's
beautiful it's beautiful and I'm
thinking of moving there wow yeah and
I'm thinking of doing it as early as uh
this summer I've been in is that easy to
get to airport so for the road from
there it's a pain in the ass no there
actually Albany airport is pretty close
Okay but it's a drag to drive into the
city because it's two hours and you hit
the GW it's like cuz I did a show in
Bushwick when I was hanging in Woodstock
last couple months and uh that was quite
a ride oh yeah into Bushwick you know
and you get used to the nature and the
bucolic right the rural setting it's so
gorgeous there like I would get up every
day look at that crazy unreal and the
house crazy to think it's that hsing
Valley man it's so close but so far it's
yeah it's just great man I love it and
there yeah just a bunch of sirens doing
yoga look at that Sirens hanging out
yeah no it's it's amazing nature for
some reason they've just got amazing
food there too it's just like it's an
artist community so it's the opposite of
stat exactly it's the anti there it's
plumbers and firemen you know
everybody's talking about 9/11 on stat a
9/11 yeah still never forget
yeah yeah 911 911 never
forget you know constantly yes
constantly he like shut the up I
know we're trying to forget we're trying
to
foret you know in Woodstock it's like
hey man what's up
what's up and people are like I know a
guy in wock who's been in a drum circle
no for about 30 years his family did an
intervention they they showed up at the
drum circle and they were like all right
look
Steve how many times can you celebrate
the sun going down because that's what
they they drum until it yeah and why
know deodorant just cuz you're drumming
you can you don't have to smell like
absolutely um I went to Occupy Wall
Street lot of lot of drum in there me
too yeah you went to it good good for
you yeah I popped in did a man on the
street yeah I wasn't really uh part of
it but I popped over I wanted to see it
I loved it I loveed man that got
exed out did they ex that
out a lot of what do you call it masing
they were just Mason people no I think
was it Bloomberg D I think so I think so
and what they did is that they just
declared all these occupy movements
health hazard that was the way they got
rid of it and they just how was it what
was the reasoning for that yeah they
said yeah I don't and that was before
the pandemic they were like it's just a
health hazard they're leaving
garbage feces by way isn't that funny
that's how people found out the outdoor
contagion uh the outdoor Co wasn't
contagious Outdoors because of like the
BLM protest is that right is that what
it was nobody got it when they were
protesting I think that was I think
people were like cuz it was the same
people scolding the Spring Breakers who
were like we got a protest and it's like
well it seems like people aren't getting
it Outdoors that's true I don't know
yeah I I agree I remember man the
pandemic was so crazy I remember there's
a great park right across the street
from where I live in LA again and I'm
walking around I'm walking around and
one of my buddies it's so funny cuz I
have a dog I meet all these people I
would never have anything to do with and
this one dude Asian guy he was like he
had a mask on outdoors and I was like
You You Wear It Outdoors huh and he's
like dude I figure it's got to be in the
air all around us and it flipped me out
you know yeah it flipped me out back
then yeah that was back when we were
cleaning mail you know we're wiping down
letters and I was naping
oranges thank God for the peel that was
like I mean Lysol wipes remember
that I got to get more Lysol was
unavailable unavailable remember they
ran out of toilet paper everywhere they
ran out of PRL it was a was a wild time
luckily I had the New York Post for
toilet
paper really shitty newspaper good
sports section though that's true and a
great tweet Twitter follow cuz their
headlines are so ridiculous that they're
easy to to joke about I like them yeah
they're fun to to grab yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah man um you been have you been
on the road a lot lately
yeah yeah you you guys every weekend
we're pushing it oh every weekend I like
the road I do too but the way I do it I
go with my buddy JT habad comic we go
City to City we don't just stay in for a
weekend okay we're bopping like today
City Winery tomorrow Philly punchline oh
next day laugh it up in pipy yep y then
I go to dojo in
Jersey then we go to Arlington
Virginia and then like so that how many
days in a row usually that's rting I
don't want to
say yeah no it it some of the trips are
like two weeks W you know and some of
the places we stay a couple of nights
but um it's a lot it's a lot like I like
it in the sense that bam you're in a new
city and you're in a new new club new
audiences and that's cool that's great
you know um and go I'd go through the
South too you know Louisiana I had a
great time in h oh wow these
people I I realized I used to be afraid
of like the South Arkansas and I
realized they love to laugh oh
yeah so I used to be uptight about the
politics and it's just
it's just people Sal of the Earth it's
amazing uh yeah some of the best shows I
had are like we I I think Knoxville
Tennessee was like my best crowd of the
Year oh interesting unbelievable
Tennessee it's amazing right yeah but
it's just cities you wouldn't expect
sometimes that and they they
come out oh h no one goes there and it
was packed I think it was a brewery yeah
it was packed and you know I talked
about I'm an animal lover which is
hilarious down there and I say I hate
the way you people trick ducks with that
bazoo thing that's you
know and I started and then after the
show they these guys who own the place
were showing me videos of their dog
dragging a deer through the woods W and
they said would you like to come with us
tomorrow on a on a hunt this is how like
a Deliverance type thing start yes
exactly you know and I was like where's
my
Zola that's how that movie would start
the dog runs up and gives it to
you yeah man it is great when you end up
being the stereotype you want and they
become the one that that you know you
both kind of fill your yeah
obligation you got the New York Jew with
the zof you got the take a of Court
you're
like good he is is that what you I yeah
no not but I do take all I take all this
I have a big thing of just you know I'm
a CVS bag with me just in you never know
I'll for like 2 weeks you you never know
what's going to happen yeah I'll go
out for a long time too sometimes so do
you do you do that do you get let me ask
you both do you get exhausted on the
road even though you like it yeah
sometimes yeah the food is shitty yeah
you get just you get numb to it where
you're just like that's true well you're
like on by day five you're just like all
right again time my day what day five
yeah you're like another another same
day it's just bad for my brain I feel
like I want to do different even
though the city is different it's almost
like the the routine is too similar yes
and then the problem is people go oh
you're going to this town you got to do
this you're like I have no time exactly
you land you go to the gig you fall you
got to eat at our fried hot dog uh fried
Oreo and you're like cool I'm been on
the road for two weeks I'm trying not to
die I'm so true man I see you're working
out too on on I have been and that is
because I go so off the rails on the
road do you guys party on the road
seriously yeah too much yeah me I smoke
a little and it it it's fun in the
moment man and also after the shows I
don't know about you guys I need to come
down you got to come down adrenaline of
course of course it's insane like
tonight coming back to New York I'm
going to have a lot of friends I haven't
seen yeah for a long time it's going to
be insane trying to be clean it's tough
I'm trying to be clean because I don't
know about you guys but when I party a
little I have no interest in working out
none of course of course you're human oh
it's but the worst with drinking is you
go man I had a bad set I need a drink
then you have a good set and you're like
let's have a drink yes you totally it
works you have an okay set you're like
well I deserve a
drink okay
set I don't settle for the
okay no you can't because if you become
an okay like that was okay right you
know that and you got to get this all in
before
2027 you know that's well you you have a
ton of funny out there I mean the
uh in runes is the other is the other
recent one that was a killer special I
loved it yeah I really I I I have a
secret weapon the guy who directs me
also helps me because I'm all over the
place in my sets I don't have a very
written thing I'm like I'm going to go
with this idea so the director stepen
finearts do you guys know Stephen anyway
he directed both my specials and
now he directs he directed Marin's laugh
special he's great and he helps me
organize my material I tape everything
and he actually has guys go through it
and say this bit this bit W and that's
kind of how I work that's nice but I
need to get more disciplined with the
writing I'm very like into the
Performing well you're great at it and I
love it the Loosey Goosey keeps it
authentic and fun right right you don't
to be too written I'm too written I
think I use a little
Eddie no but you you do a lot of like
off the cuff I do it at the end you
do too yeah just cuz I'm bored with the
set yeah of course and I'm just I want
to do new I also yeah you get isn't it
great I mean that's why we I feel like
that's the rush of it I used to open for
a TA and and uh and he would I could
tell be so bored with the ridden stuff
that he would just bring you up on stage
at the end and you would just
around with the tell which by the way
it's like that's however quick you think
you are you're not quicker than dve
unbelievable so it it would be a thing
where I'd be like well first off I'll
never get a high self-esteem working
with this guy like I'm never going to be
like I'm funny you're like no
you just don't you're like I'm fine I'm
whatever he's he's the quickest he is
it's insane I this is what I skankfest
right mhm um oh I saw you there yeah
right right he came up after me right
and I had just finished like a rant
about the military industrial complex
and a t comes up and he goes wow this
guy is uh really for the people and it's
funny because he looks like he makes his
own ice cream I didn't even know what
that meant but it was so funny it's so
funny I saw him last night at Gotham he
was at Gotham him last night I got yeah
and he had some great new stuff and he
had a moment where he
went and the crowd was like huh he goes
sorry I had a little
fetterman I was like what a great what a
great uh way to cover that you know oh
man so funny to say that he's I mean we
talk about him so much in this podcast
cuz we just all I well I just feel every
New York Comic loves davel so his name
just comes up so much and he's so New
York I don't hardly ever see him out in
La no he's outside smoking a cigarette
when he's there he's not in the club
he's outside having a cigarette you know
but I remember seing him once at The
Improv in LA and it was just so weird
it's weird we both were like what and
I'm like I know and he's like I know it
just didn't feel right but but it's it's
so fun to run into him uh I know what
you're thinking I look like I work in
gun
safety yeah he's I remember one my
favorite atel memories was like I
remember we did Terry Town Music Hall
and we were driving back and he was so
good but he just he was like I
stink I'm the worst I'm the worst
because he was doing did did he
feel like he was doing the same stuff
why did he say that I cuz he does it all
the time he'll kill and he'll say that
and and I was like d is he serious oh
yeah oh yeah so he's a real comic d
I mean but is isn't it weird but like
because we're like mad that he feels
that way but the part of us is like
keeps him great I don't know it does
well isn't that the Dunning Krueger the
dumb guy thinks he's smart and the smart
you know the bad comic thinks he's
brilliant and hilarious and then the
great comic thinks he's a hack but I
remember driving back with him being
like Dave what what are you talking
about we all think you're the best and
he was like well I'm funnier than you
guys oh that's the best wow it's good
that he knows that cuz sometimes he's so
down to yourself you're like do you know
how great you are but I think he knows a
little bit and he'll still Zing you he's
the he's the best you know but
um how long did you uh tour with Dave
not that long it was it was never like I
was his every week guy but it would be
like you know you remember it' be like
every so often right we would and he was
just so fun to be out still go out with
him here and there no I don't see him as
often because I have uh you're all over
no also that but we still do the seller
but Dave shows up at like 1:00 a.m. and
I have drilling on my building for the
last 14 months that starts at 8:00 a.m.
so I can't call late anymore right oh
man but uh yeah he's a treat to see
though but he'll go he'll show up really
late usually oh yeah he by the way just
to get this in pet
peeve construction yeah uhoh is
so ubiquitous it's so all over the
place it's wild and I just heard
Drilling in your building oh my god well
we can I'll send Clips they're
insane you've you've seen them on the
Pod but I'll send you one Matt to play
up they're insane it's wild what
he's showing is comical it's it's like a
bit it's un I I don't know about you but
I as I've gotten older too I'm so
sensitive to noise yes same you too
noise and light yeah lights too yeah I
got a light in my eye I'm ruined I'm
trying to get a nap on the plane the one
guy's got the shade open
with the shade open 7: a.m. close the
right do you ever say
anything n me neither one timey Rush
that's my window by the
way look at this no that's your window
yeah I just sent you another one Matt
this is a more recent one that's
insane wow and that's hours yeah 8:00
a.m. wow 8 a.m. yeah yeah it's crazy 8
a.m. what do you do Sam do you have you
complained yeah but they just don't give
I mean it's City they don't care
but I'll show you uh yeah I just send
you a new one there there's more this
great for an audio podcast by the way
I'm like listen to the worst thing no
it's video too look look at this
wow I love that you're documenting
it and by the way it's like I know some
people like it's not that bad the
apartment's vibrating yeah they
think you're at work that's the problem
crazy it makes but like it's been like
14 months so I'm like I'm going a little
crazy 14 months that apparently it's
been 3 years I've only lived there 14
months but I'm dude where is it it's uh
in the village but I'm dude I'm L it's I
love the area but I'm I'm literally
walking around like my head you
know when you when you're just like not
right and then you sleep well for one
day and you're like man I feel like
you're like ho do you s better on the
road dude it's I sleep in hotel in those
hotels like they think I'm dead a lot of
time they check
on they send what they call a checker
like hit you with a
stick sir sir
sir it is crazy how much better I sleep
on the road same here and if the bed is
Awesome on the road like sometimes I
like you what I feel like every Hotel
pillow sucks I hate the pillows but then
when you go to the upscale hotels I
still still kind of they I don't I feel
like it's all the same I've gotten a few
good pillows have you ever thought of
taking a terrific goose down pillow with
you I used to and it's it's insane psych
you're a psycho I travel with a my
pillow I don't know I try to the pillow
I just really like him and Mike Lidell
whatever he's a great guy that was
hilarious so you see that clip of him
just losing it when the guy questioned
the quality of his pillow like that's
the did he lose it oh he was like he was
like how dare you it's a great pillow
and you're like all right well at least
at least he stands behind it I mean he
made it in the basement got divorced
through the whole thing it was a real
Endeavor wow good for him were you were
you going to be coming up like in
December and stuff on the road check it
out after this tour ends like the 20th
I'm not back on the road until February
oh wow and you know what I need that
break I just need it because boom boom
boom boom boom all over this year big
time that's a great one what do you
think of the website I love it my
podcast apocalypse soon great which 2027
I guess now is the date yeah um yeah
eclips I see are hilarious oh yeah I was
on one I think I think I was on an
episode yeah that's right was it over
Zoom yeah yeah that might have been at
the very beginning of that you know I
love the dojo you that's a fun room it
is right yeah it's nice and little and
fun the Crowds Are banging Whitney
Cummings was on here by the way talking
about how her favorite bit is you
heckling yourself oh that's a lot of
people love that one that they love that
overseas have you guys done a bunch of
Performing overseas yes we're just
starting depends on the city it's not a
all great the what it depends on the
city I did and this is brutal twice the
Edinburgh Fringe Festival wow 20 check
this out 28 shows an hour no opener in
29 days one day off and every day is
like Groundhog Day yeah and
Scotland and Edinburgh is beautiful
Edinburgh particularly is like
beautiful you know did you enjoy it the
first year I killed and I had all this
I then got Oslo and Melbourne
burn um uh where else did I go oh
I've been going back and forth
to Amsterdam still you know it's like a
it's like a market it's like a World
Market so you're seen by all these
people all over right you know
where you guys Soho theater I did a few
times in London yeah we I just did
London this year you did where uh Lester
how is that Lester Square amazing yeah I
was going to say uh I mean your hour
must have gotten airtight from doing it
the what the your must have been dude it
it really it was like going it was like
going through a fire and you
come out you're like I was a better
comic for it for it oh yeah yeah it's
weird that that misery and that
repetition like it's like the equivalent
of the gym for an athlete it's like it
sucks abs and I came back I did it twice
I then did it four years later with not
as much success I I don't know what the
happened and they could be brutal
this guy this guy CS they could be like
you so not suck they say
something they say like you're
no good peppone that's worse
than you suck yeah yeah oh yeah not not
quite as harsh as yes it's not quite as
harsh so it lands better did a a month
in Europe just Dublin Berlin Lisbon
Scotland was the last night it was going
great my hour was cooking I got heckled
in Scotland and Glasgow for an hour came
out and they're like look at this
just out of the game they love doing
that they're testing you but I wasn't
ready and you know when the opener comes
off and he gives you one of these oh
you're like uhoh what's going to happen
oh yeah I mean they were this close to
throwing a bottle on the stage and they
didn't they liked me that was the weird
part and they liked you yeah do you ever
hear of the Glasco kiss yes you know
what the Glasco kiss on a headbutt he
told us that yeah the Glasco kiss that's
what they call it damn that is hilarious
tough down no where else have you gone
around the around the world do you want
me to say I've done Dublin yeah great we
didn't we do Dublin Mark yeah we did the
vone Fest years ago that's what I did
Brent Barry yeah I love that guy I love
those guys and I forget the other guy we
got we got we had a great experience if
it was like me Mark Colin Quinn Nate
barazi Chris Steph like a great group of
Rachel just like everyone there was
like a great hang it could have been
better that's so that's great it's a
great great little town I this is what I
love about performing overseas and
especially at a Fest I love seeing other
comedians from around the world and I
find some of the London guys to
be incredible and the a couple irish
guys Tommy tiin oh we saw him there
Phenom nobody knows him here he's
incredible he's how about Stuart
Lee in England yeah he's big yeah great
writ holy what a smart comic I know
some might say too smart yeah yeah I
have his book you do yeah I didn't read
it but I have it his wife is
brilliant really brilliant all right
I'll believe it when I see
it yeah we're starting to do it more and
more I was I mean I supposed to go to
like Israel in April that a't yeah it
was but I mean that was on the I'm
supposed to do a lot of Europe in in uh
in April so we'll see yeah I just can't
I'm I don't know I two weeks from now
I'm doing Gaza
yeah no I'm telling my manager no and
he's pushing me it'll still be good he's
like we're trying to get you a better
deal
think cause a strip mall that'll be
tough a strip just it's just a funny
bone but it's right that you're
like no women
openers oh my God you're in the Green
Room you're like can I get a
quesadilla quesadilla you
know um yeah so do you have your dates
for February up for no no um I'm going
what am I doing Napa Valley it's great
cuz I'm going to be and I just came back
from Northern
California which was it's a whole
different world up there it really is
man you ever play Humbolt County no
seriously it fits The Stereotype
everybody is stoned it's the pot center
of the world humble you see the
documentary murder Mountain on Netflix
watch it it's about marijuana growers oh
I think I did see that it's amazing or
at least some of it yeah yeah oh some of
it it doesn't sound like you enjoyed
it I guess you had to get back to the
sori there it is I didn't I thought
there was something else no I haven't
seen this oh it's a it it's like
riveting you like docks yeah right you
get hooked into them this one I can't
wait I'm going to watch this you're
going to love it and it's like
four or five parts so you kill like
you're good until next Wednesday these
people up there are so Progressive
they're those kind kind of progressive
that they won't take a vaccine cuz
they're like the government made it you
know they go all the way the other way
that's true too but they're also loaded
to the teeth with guns exactly so they
have this blend of like yes yes this
kind of a Libertarian yeah that that guy
in the mask what a character huh
liberals with guns like Vermont people
yeah is that what it is mix Vermont is
like that it's like an alt-right trans
good good club there I have fun there
Vermont Comedy Club
I for some reason hate the
crowds I is that right I know what
you're saying I know what you're saying
they're like they're like on drugs or
something they're like not laughing I'm
like this is well it's a little PC right
something I I don't even know if it's PC
I think they're like I are they dead
inside they might be dead inside yeah it
that may be money like have you ever
performed in Aspen no but that used to
be where they did the big Fest right mhm
mhm those people are like to make them
laugh is like very difficult so I just
go after them that's what they want I
open with hello
scum not kidding I feel the same about
Hawaii oh
dude strg down I I was they tried to
Route it with Australia to make
Australia easier on me and I'm like I
don't want to I don't want to why is
beautiful I'm sure beautiful that's why
they're not fun crowds and that is
exactly right Kyle Canan and me did a
festival there the Maui Comedy Festival
I did that you did and we only lasted a
couple of years did they put you up in
the Hilton an in hotel and they gave us
rental cars unbelievable they blew their
whole W green sand beaches and before
this huge disastrous fire but Maui
canine goes to me right before I go up
at some venue he goes I can't wait to
see what these people are going to think
of your end of the world
because it's Paradise exactly what
do they have to so they don't care about
our bed what's up with cereal what I
live on a mountain you know exactly
exactly yeah um well that I will we'll
we'll see you next
week yeah and listen to watch Eddie all
Eddie specials all killer listen to his
podcast Apocalypse Now really one of the
funniest Comics out there if you don't
know his stuff I mean big fans over here
sorry about that I had some thanks you
guys some
T all right I'm Markman comedy.com uh
for dates you know I'm coming right to
your town you don't say tour rolling on
and shows added so we're coming to
Florida Columbus Ohio Indianapolis New
York New York at the Beacon Lexington
Kentucky Charlotte San Anton Houston
Boise Salt Lake Atlanta Raleigh Austin
Tucson Phoenix charlotteville Charleston
El Paso alquerque Memphis Tennessee
Little Rock where does this go to from
from when to when from now till summer
damn oh yeah now what do you got there
Sone I got Vegas Tampa Fort Meyers and H
Buffalo Springfield Missouri I'm I'm
back uh I'm I'm getting in shape for the
uh for the next special in March so we
got Madison Philly Miami Beach Dana
Beach sorry you're doing another special
in March yeah we won't stop Dallas OKC
Irvine Sal Lake City and then we're
doing the Wilbur so I think that's
almost sold out so uhow can't wait we'll
see you guys uh wow four nights at the
Wilbur uh two I think oh two two shows
we might do three we might do three
we'll see uh but I can't wait it's going
to be uh it's going to be a fun run hell
yeah I got I got to write some new
for I feel like I got the hour I got to
write some new for after that's
what these clubs are for like let me
write some new so I can so
I can have an act when do you write it
on your feet basically like kind of in
the club or because that's when we're
flowing I don't know what you think but
that on stage we're flowing whereas when
you're in your apartment going it's
tough hell is funny yeah Radiators R
radiator oh I know drilling yeah I find
that I can write I write in the
apartment or the coffee shop whatever
and then I tag on the road I feel like
that's where I get my cuz I need the
premise before I go bring on stage nice
but well guys drink Bodega cat whiskey
at bodegacat whiskey.com we love you uh
Eddie peperone check out all his stuff
and uh and we'll see you next
[Music]
week and I get down in the same
way up on the roof like a
coming and naked Samuel is feeling
dangerous I'm out to lunch here in New
Orleans
thises I
remember and
[Music]
get we
might
be
true